hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today the government
releases its strategy for Net Zero but
environmental groups threaten legal
action
a small town in Minnesota is evacuated
after a train carrying ethanol derails
catching a light
and the Australian government passes key
legislation to cut emissions and
Crackdown on polluters
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show the show where we track the changes
to our world and report on some of the
solutions to The Climate crisis
now the government has today announced
updated plans that it says will allow
Britain to reach Net Zero by 2050. it's
in response to legal action from Green
campaigners who argue that current
policies don't meet the country's legal
obligations but campaigners say the near
3 000 page strategy falls short of the
ambition required and are threatening to
take the government back to court
so let's take a look at some of the
measures that have been announced today
well the energy security and Net Zero
secretary Grant Sharps announced a 20
billion pound pledge to invest in carbon
capture that's the unproven technology
that plans the suck carbon back out of
the atmosphere
there was also a pledge of 160 million
pounds to expand offshore wind projects
but notably not onshore wind
the government also confirmed that it
would be investing more than 380 million
pounds into boosting EV charging
infrastructure
and a commitment to insulate 300 000 of
the over 20 million homes in Britain
and there's also 240 million pounds of
funding for hydrogen projects
plus more details on Great British
nuclear to support the growth of the
nuclear industry
and an extension of the existing heat
pump subsidy scheme that'll run now
until 2028.
well I'm joined now in the studio
bicycle is climate change and energy
correspondent to Hannah Thomas Peter
who's been speaking with Grant shaft so
first of all Hannah what did he have to
say well I pressed him on whether or not
he was trying to have his cake and eat
it by pledging all of this
decarbonization work but at the same
time approving new oil and gas licenses
he said that we simply in the UK cannot
just turn off the tap and then that's a
long phased out process he did
acknowledge though that on the demand
side the insulation of heat pumps which
is way way off track just simply hadn't
gone fast enough and that we needed to
do much more on insulating homes and
that you know there are millions and
millions of homes that need insulation
and only a couple of hundred thousand
are covered in this plan
um I actually asked him in the end did
he believe could he promise the British
public that this would be enough to do
that very complicated tight rope walk of
enhancing energy security and at the
same time delivering Net Zero and this
is what he said
yes that's a exactly the plan and the
reason that I'm confident about this is
I have more stake in this than pretty
much anyone else and that's because the
secretary of state is personally
required by law to get us to Net Zero by
2050 that's not a matter of sort of it
would be quite nice to do the ultimate
sanction is that the Secretary of State
can go to prison
and Hannah what about subsidies because
there is a concern isn't there that the
UK could be left behind the US and the
EU as well who are promising big
subsidies to Green Industries this is
all about the inflation reduction act
that President Joe Biden passed 370
billion dollars aimed at really boosting
the the Green Revolution in the U.S is
already tempting money across the
Atlantic the EU has responded with a
similar kind of deal real concerns
within the renewable industry that um
wind power in particular will be left
behind when we generated such a good
lead over the last decade and a half or
so and I think that uh this was in part
supposed to be a response to that but
I've been speaking to people in the
Renewables industry this afternoon they
have said that while they welcome some
of the progress that's being made
there's nowhere near enough here they
need a better tax incentives they need
more capital expenditure allowance they
need to be able to write off Investments
for more than just three years what they
government's promising at the moment and
they are still worried even after these
announcements that the government hasn't
done enough to shore up wind power for
the future in this country okay Hannah
thanks very much indeed
well we're gonna have some more expert
views on that top story in a moment but
first let's take a quick look at some of
the day's other news and in the last few
hours residents of a small town in the
American state of Minnesota have fled
their homes after a train carrying
ethanol and corn syrup has derailed and
caught fire the Train derailed in the
town of Raymond roughly 100 miles west
of Minneapolis at around 1am local time
according to a statement from the local
sheriff the rail Freight industry is
under intense scrutiny after a train
carrying toxic chemicals derailed in
Ohio last month causing thousands to be
evacuated and raising concerns about
long-term Health impacts
the Australian Parliament has passed
Landmark new laws aimed at helping the
country reach its Target of Net Zero by
2050. the so-called Safeguard mechanism
reforms will create a ceiling for
emissions and force Australia's 215 most
polluting facilities to reduce their
emissions by 4.9 percent each year long
seen as a Lagarde on emissions reduction
Australia's new labor government says
it's committed to climate action
Australians had seen the devastating
impact of climate change it's not
something that's theoretical the
bushfires the floods the fact that the
science told us it would be more extreme
weather events and they'd be more
intense has tragically played out
passing this legislation has put
Australia on a realistic path to net
zero emissions by 2050 and a 43
reduction by 2030.
has ordered the US government to resume
regular oil and gas lease sales on
federal lands in North Dakota the Biden
Administration reached a legal
settlement to reassess the climate
damages from the leases in September
after halting the practice two years ago
around a quarter of U.S fossil fuels
come from federal lands
now for more on our top story now on the
government's Net Zero strategy I'm
joined by the energy and climate
intelligence units head of energy Jess
Ralston and the policy director at the
Grantham Research Institute on climate
change at lse Bob Ward so hello to both
of you thanks so much for talking to us
just to you first of all overall are you
impressed by the plans
well the strategy today and all the
government's announcements were billed
as a new energy security strategy now
the U.N the United Nations of course the
International Energy agency and the UK's
climate change committee have all said
that in order to get greater energy
Independence we need to build out more
Renewables and reduce our gas demand in
the first place through things like
insulation and on those fronts the
government strategy doesn't quite give
the Renewables industry what they wanted
in terms of a boost of certainty that
the UK is where they should invest their
money nor is there no new money
announced for Energy Efficiency and
which certainly doesn't help to reduce
our gas demand okay and but Bob there is
a focus on new technologies isn't there
like hydrogen but also carbon capture
storage the hope the government says is
that a common capture storage could
remove 50 of the emissions on these on
this country's industry which sounds
great
yeah I mean and we are going to need
carbon capture and storage but it's
let's be very clear that we will need it
for dealing with those parts of the
economy where you can't easily replace
fossil fuels with Alternatives uh
perhaps in in aspects of steel industry
or maybe even
um uh cement manufacture but we
shouldn't be using it really in the
power industry to help us keep burning
fossil fuels that doesn't make a lot of
sense where we have a lot of uh cheaper
alternatives in Renewables and
um we already see we are seeing at the
moment the consequences of our
dependence on fossil fuels it is the
price of natural gas that went up as a
result of Russia's invasion of Ukraine
that has caused our energy crisis and
caused our cost of living crisis so by
tackling the climate change crisis we
will we will help prevent us being as
exposed and as vulnerable to Future
um uh problem problems which we see from
time to time with the volatility and the
price of fossil fuels well just the
government would no doubt say that it is
doing that it's putting a real focus in
these plans on nuclear and a
confirmation of the launch of the the
Great British nuclear which is going to
focus on on small reactors in particular
they also say that they're incentivizing
Renewables as well now you touched on
this before are you satisfied that those
elements of the plan go far enough
well that's you there's quite a
disconnect at the moment and not a very
Level Playing Field between the tax
breaks and the investment allowances
that the oil and gas industry get
compared to those that the Renewables
industry get and for example in the
windfall tax on oil and gas companies
everybody knows that they've made huge
win for profits over the past year or so
there's an investment allowance there
that allows them to claim back 90p in
every pound they spend but there isn't
one of those for Renewables Investments
so you know the Renewables industry are
saying to the government you're saying
you're going to need lots more
investment into this Renewables industry
in the UK yet you're giving the oil and
gas companies more tax breaks and more
investment allowances than we get so
there's a bit of a you know confusion
with the energy security strategy here
what is the plan for decarbonizing our
homes and as Bob says moving away from
oil and gas and will help us to shield
from future volatility in those markets
so there's a lot left to be desired by
today's plans and the Renewables
industry as an investor you're going to
look at the UK and look at it in the
context of what the US are offering the
EU offering and you might just choose to
go there instead and very briefly Jess
is there enough detail on what the plans
are to perhaps allow for onshore wind
well in the documents that I've seen so
far no there's no real mention of
onshore wind
um it's not clear how the government
plans on lifting the ban as they've said
they will
um they've talked a lot about local
consultation and local approvals but
there's no clear plan for how they're
going to try and achieve this
um and onshore wind is one of the
cheapest if not the cheapest source of
power so it could really help to lower
our bills in the long term and shielders
from those spiky gas prices
um but a lack of clarity is just not
helpful for people who are looking to
invest in the UK nor is it helpful for
our bills which are still high despite
the gas price falling a little bit and
Bob one way of reducing bills and
Emissions is to reduce demand to stop
using so much energy the government is
talking about helping insulate 300 000
of the poorest performing homes as far
as insulation is concerned they're also
trying to extend this scheme to make it
cheaper for people to install heat pump
so are they doing enough on that front
well the real secret here is
government's got to at this stage when a
lot of these alternative fossil fuels
are still a little bit more expensive
than the fossil fuel alternative is that
the government needs to provide support
to Consumers and business to be able to
introduce them now at the moment it's
got this boiler upgrade scheme that is
meant to bring down the price of price
of heat pumps to make them equivalent to
the price of a new gas boiler but that's
not good enough in order to get the kind
of really strong move towards heat pumps
uh which we have to do then you're going
to need to make it cheaper in the short
run we know that we expect over the long
run and as you manufacture more heat
pumps the cost of production will come
down and eventually it will be cheaper
anyway just on the open market to buy a
heat pump rather than a gas boiler but
at the moment the government is not
investing enough similarly with electric
cars we need to make electric cars
cheaper to buy at the moment than their
potential or diesel equivalent I just
reason one more question just to you the
government was forced to produce at this
revised plan because the high court
found that its strategy didn't meet its
climate targets have they plugged the
gap
it remains unclear to be perfectly
honest you know there's a lot of
documents to get through a lot of pages
of writing
um and there's some discussion about
whether the government has released just
so much today to try and distract from
the fact
um that it maybe hasn't done what it
said it was going to do in terms of our
emissions reductions but let's be clear
about this the intergovernmental panel
on climate change in the recent report
said that if we don't reach Net Zero
climate change will not be halted and
the impacts will get worse including
those here in the UK like droughts and
heat waves and so this really is a
matter of urgency okay well just Rawson
and Bob Ward really get good to get your
expertise and your views on this thanks
very much indeed
thank you
now just a reminder that you can catch
the climate Show with Tom Heat this
weekend that's at 3 P.M and 7 30 p.m on
Saturday and Sunday and this week Tom's
in Sussex looking at a project to
restore Britain's lost kelp forests but
that's all for today thanks for watching
[Music]